a lot of the abuse took place inside the
church inside the house of God saying no
to him would almost be saying like no to
God and when have you ever said no to
God I was sexually abused by a Catholic
priest from the age of 11 to 16 when I
was between the ages of 15 and 17 years
old I was sexually abused by a teacher
at a private Catholic High School in
Southern California with me it started
with long conversations about my mom and
how I was alone then he started telling
me secrets and he wanted me to share
those secrets with nobody else then it
moved into the kissing and the touching
and within a few months I was being it
was full-blown sexual abuse and it was
so bad by the time that the piece ended
I was 17 and I was pregnant and I had a
sexually transmitted disease I remember
one time I was in class I must have been
in the sixth grade or something like
that one of the nuns came into the
classroom and said father financee wants
to see you I get to the sacristy I go
upstairs and so he tells me that he's
drawing a picture of a rising Christ for
Easter he asked me if I want to model
for him and at that point he says well
you got to take off all your clothes and
so he makes me take off my underwear and
then he has me lay down on the ground
and he starts putting me out in
different poses you know you're a
crucified Jesus so I put my arms out I
put my head to one side put my head to
the other side starts manipulating my
legs my arms my torso he reaches down
starts playing with my penis so then he
tells me well now you need to start
beating off you gotta masturbate and
ejaculate didn't take pictures of me and
at that point he just gives me my
clothes get dressed and go back to
school
in 2001 and this is before the Boston
Globe covered the crisis in Boston which
is chronicled in the spotlight film we
had a scandal here in California and a
boy who had been sexually abused by my
high school principal came forward and
filed a lawsuit he ended up getting
documents that showed that the diocese
knew that my high school principal have
been abusing boys for years and they'd
even set him to a church run treatment
facility where they send priests who
sexually molest kids as they go through
the seminary students they're very
controlled everything is documented in
fact the priests who abused me has
documentation that goes all the way back
to the seminary that he was out there
exhibiting unusual behavior by drawing
you know men's penises and all kinds of
other things and walking around naked I
contacted the diocese where I lived and
I said hey this happened to me and I
want to be a part of the solution and
they told me well why don't you sit on
our lay Review Board where you can
review cases where you know adults have
come forward and said they were sexually
abused as children by priests and
employees and volunteers and I sat on
that committee for about six months and
we didn't review a single case and I
began to realize that I was being played
again like I had been played in high
school they were buying my silence by
putting me on this board
in the end my lawsuit settled and I got
more than 200 pages of documents secret
documents spotlight documents in my case
and they included the signed confession
from the man who sexually abused me
he confessed to abusing me and he
confessed to abusing my friends I got
secret documents from school
administrators who said oh yeah we knew
that this was going on
we knew that Jamal was being sexually
abused and we decided to keep it quiet
because it was better that way
the Catholic Church is very good at
keeping records in fact they have a
rulebook it's called the code of canon
law those are the rules and regulations
at bishops and priests and employees and
Catholics have to follow and a lot of
those rules have to do with documenting
sin and documenting child sexual abuse
for victims it's been a lifesaver
because it's been the proof that we have
needed all along to say hey this really
happened
I'm still a Catholic I was born a
Catholic I'll diet Catholic I certainly
believe that in order to take care of
this Catholic problem it has to be done
by a Catholic the moment that I step
outside the church I'm considered an
outsider and I no longer have a voice
faith is a one-on-one relationship you
have with a Supreme Being and I don't
need a guy in a Roman collar to tell me
what my relationship with God has to be
you